what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame live from Dallas
um before I start big shout out to the
purple pill podcast for letting us use
their Studio the link to their channel
is in the description
um also before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef quick plug before
we start the show
um we have four membership tiers the
first membership tier gets to be a part
of the live chat the second membership
tier you get to be a part of our Discord
and our behind the scenes Vlogs third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month I
highly recommend this if you're trying
to grow on YouTube I've helped people
get to ten thousand twenty thousand
thirty thousand and even a hundred
thousand subscribers in just a couple
sessions so sign up for that if you
would like to grow on YouTube
so um today I have a lovely panel a lot
of familiar faces here why don't we go
around everyone say your name your age
your relationship status and a fun fact
about yourself and you can plug any
channels now if you want to too starting
here and go around hi everybody Dawn I
am La Peep Jr from the La Peep Network
ages 39 relationship status I am in
relationship and
a fun fact about me is I don't like
giving up
I'm Shantel from Chantel Simone I'm 31.
I am in a relationship and fun fact I am
left-handed
my name is Diana I'm 27. I am in a
relationship and fun fact about me is
um I'm in real estate okay
hey I'm Jesse um Jessica Barrera and I'm
31. I let's see fun fact I've lived in
Europe for several years and bounced
around different cities that's
interesting fact
hey everybody good to meet you my name
is Sir Hale from Sir Hill speaks I am 35
married to 15 years and a fun fact about
me is I play the piano
I'm Austin Holloman 23.
I'm single
and I can speak Portuguese
so today's topic is we're going to be
talking about modern dating
so
overall the total number of marriages
recorded in the U.S in 2020 was the
lowest it has been since 1963. in
addition the marriage rate which was
measured which measures the number of
marriages per thousand people plummeted
from 6.1 marriages per a thousand to
just 5.1 why do you think men and women
can't seem to get together
you talk about right now currently
currently uh if I had to say based off
them stats you said
you've got to realize that we was in a
pandemic so I think a lot of the
courthouses and a lot of things just
shut down I think that number might have
spiked in 2021 if we had those stats but
I think due to everything that was going
on that's where the dip happened a
pandemic what do you think the feminist
movement why but is the feminist
movement encouragement
to me door men and um don't need a man
then you don't need marriage so we we
want or men to provide but at the same
time we want to be or independent so
that created a disconnect that affected
the marriage rate in my opinion and so
you think it's it's when do you think
since like the 1920s like when or 1988 I
believe was when the feminist movement
yeah like around that time
um like around the 1970s 1980s okay when
um women started want the need to be
liberated okay okay what do you think I
think a lot of people don't want to get
married nowadays why I think they like
to be independent and have their own do
you think that's the men and the women
I think it's mostly women that want to
be independent yes and why do you think
that is
I think nowadays like women just want to
have like their own and don't really
want to depend on a man for anything so
almost like a backup plan okay yeah I
think there's too many distractions
nowadays I think people are in
relationships and don't want to fully
commit I don't know if it's because I
mean I've seen a lot with social media
people are distracted there's too many
options or they're always thinking okay
maybe there'll be a plan b or something
better will come along I think that I've
seen it a lot with um friends and I
guess even in my own personal cases do
you think that's the men the women or
both definitely both both yeah
oh so I'll start off with the term
because modern women are chaotic and
they want to live like holes
they want the power the privilege that
Independence provides she said it better
than I did they don't want the structure
that masculinity brain so it's easy to
get attention from social media and to
give dates and to get what you want on
the outside without obligations or
responsibility so modern women are the
reason 98.2 I mean I give you the
research 98 responsible for the decline
in marriage today why do you say 98 we
can't even give the men ten percent
well I say the relationships if it if it
succeeds or it fails it's largely
largely on women I mean we'll do
anything for the woman they care about
so that's why I say that okay go ahead I
blame it on the feminists because they
convince women that they're equal to men
and y'all are not
and uh y'all feel like y'all don't need
us at all and you really do you know if
World War III started today all that
[ __ ] would go out the window we could
run into the friend zone
you'd be ready to be married
no more distractions
um so um a lot of so I'm going to key in
on something you said
um that that women want to be
independent right do you think that
women should 100 depend on their men or
should they have a backup plan
I'll say 100 depend on your man
um that way when you feel like you want
to leave
you kind of can't nothing obviously not
in like you know a slavery way but yeah
um yeah you need to 100 depend on your
man okay what do you guys think I think
you should always have a backup plan
okay just in case it's almost like a
retirement plan here we go yeah I
completely disagree with you
um I any relationship I've ever been in
I always kind of put in the same work
work the same amount and it's always
been easier to split whenever you don't
rely completely on on your male partner
yeah the goal of a relationship is not
to split easily though
that's true but I don't think putting uh
being completely 100 dependent that
makes it seem like the females you know
just giving her all to the man and not
like
feeling any on her own where is she
that's the goal you think yeah so so
where's the woman why so he's a real
issue here like women should 100 trust
their man the reason why depending on
the man seems such like a hard thing is
because you don't trust him and women
who don't trust their men and have to
depend on them end up resenting them and
that's where you're going to see these
with the sneaky links on the side
because he's providing something that
that man that you depend on can't have
so it's a real the real issue here is
not being able to depend on him because
most men you can it's do you trust him
are you willing to mm-hmm
wives depend on their men
100 100 percent
do you think that you can have kids with
a guy and not depend on him
no no
so then how how would they always have a
backup plan if they're having kids with
a guy
I just mean when I think about it
financially maybe we'll put it into that
perspective if a woman is not working
and depending on her relationship 100
and then if they decide to break then
what's she gonna do but you know having
kids I think it has to be a
collaborative between the male the man
and the woman there's no way that just
one can I mean you can raise you know
somebody no offense to any single
mothers out there I think it's a great
thing to be able to do but
um to have both in the relationship is
so important yeah you know it's
interesting like why do we fear this
when women are the ones that leave
like men aren't leaving women leave 70
to 80 of the time and if they're call if
you're college educated you leave 90 of
the time
so it's interesting like it seems like
we as women have a fear of being left
but we're the ones leaving
that's because y'all never know what
y'all
what yeah we don't usually
seriously
I think that just a sense of confidence
and
and days and like you can handle it on
your own as well and like you don't
necessarily need that 100 provider like
you mentioned earlier yeah in Brazil
they know what they want
so we think it's like something between
countries or it's not feminism isn't as
heavy down there it's there though I
also think it's fair I'm sorry I think
it's fair why we want to have our backup
plan we want to have our own
um just in case he cheats or just in
case you know those movies told us that
men cheats so I'm just in case he cheats
let's not depend on him 100 but as Sir
Hill speaks if you trust your man then
do you think if a guy cheats on you it
should be over oh no no
wow what do you guys think
not at all no
go ahead a lot of women think that
cheating for a man means something it
means nothing a man can do what he does
and not know
he forgot about you right so for a
minute means nothing but if a woman does
that it she it meant something yeah
yeah
yeah
what what do you guys think if he cheats
is it are you leaving is it over
I think it depends on the circumstances
I will give somebody one chance but if
it's a repetitive thing absolutely not
and I don't know Sarah you said that a
man doesn't feel anything when they
cheat nothing not really
no emotional connection at all when it
comes to sexual intercourse nothing
after after he clinches that's it that's
it
do you agree from a male perspective do
you agree that the male doesn't have any
feeling sorry yes yes I'm gonna say that
that 100 agree with that there are times
they make and have sex with a woman and
it's like that posting that Clarity it's
it's it is what it is now in some rare
cases I do believe that it may be a
special woman it might be able to grab
his attention but she has to really be
exhibiting something that's just out of
the ordinary out of the norm yeah the
majority of women you just getting out
the way so no do you do you guys think
there is ever a line like that a girl
should leave like if it's like excessive
like if he's if he's screwing a new girl
every single night or if it's like what
I'm just curious from a guy's point of
view is there ever a line that a guy
could cross when it comes to cheating
where she should leave
I think she should be ashamed of herself
if that man feels so lonely oh my God
I go find something else I think that
woman needs to take a personal look at
himself and figure out why that man is
not being taken care of it's it goes
against our American values and I think
the one has to look at herself okay okay
what if what if he knocks another girl
up should she leave
[Music]
one of his siblings was like a uh not
like a love out of marriage child that
he knocked her up and he said and he was
the youngest so his dad like stayed with
the white like they stayed together and
they had another kid
so what do you think should she leave if
you should definitely I have a brother
liked it
it was somebody that my dad was fooling
around with for like 15 years and I
didn't know 15 years wow wow actually
like two or three of them so did you
have I mean if 15 years is a long time
do you think it was just sex or did he
actually no I was more than six okay my
mom had some problems with that that's
why I can understand why you said she
needs to take a look at herself my mom's
not that's kind of coming back then
though right what 15 or 15 years no no
what I'm saying is that I think a lot of
men had separate families back in the
day
and nine times out of ten the woman
would know about it but she just played
a role she played a position so I think
it was more accepted back in the day
than it is right now but is that a bad
thing well this boy is 13.
is that a bad thing that it was more
accepted back in the days I mean family
stayed together well I think the in my
opinion I think the focus was more so on
he was a good man he's a cat household
so as long as he did that then there
were some things that might have been
excused or may have been overlooked it
may not necessarily been the right thing
but the fact that he was a provider for
that house that was the importance
what are you guys so what do you guys
think he knocks another girl up you
leaving you're leaving yeah yeah I'm
leaving I'm leaving 100 percent
[Laughter]
it's a different story when you uh
um okay another question I had
if a relationship so nowadays it's
it's the majority of relationships have
to be somewhat closer to 50 50 maybe 60
40 70 30 whatever it is but it seems
like it's less and less common that
um people are relying on one income it's
usually two
if if a woman is going 50 50 on the
bills is the woman doing more work in
the relationship
no
why because those are the women that
want to hire a chef and all that
nonsense
come on keep going no I mean those are
they they're at work they're playing
both roles so no they're not they
usually don't do anything
seriously I disagree my last my previous
ly 50 and then at home I was doing
cleaning cooking taking care of the
house in addition so I think that's
you have to agree that that's putting in
more work if you're putting in the same
it's just automated today come on we got
a dishwasher laundry machine it's like
it's automated
like 20 minutes
I'm not asking you to Betty Crocker out
here maybe the Southern Roots the key is
there no no okay you weren't doing
that for two people
is that all right but if you're
contributing is it not considered you
know doing the doing more work what is
he doing
with work work
um taking I mean we're both contributing
okay
she's about to say something I want to
hear what she's about to say go ahead no
no I wasn't gonna say anything in
addition yeah
what about like what does doesn't he
like fix stuff and like fix the car oil
change that's true yeah yeah you can't
do an oil change I wasn't checking like
this
I think I think a lot of women use
marriage and relationships as like a
financial safety net so that they'll get
in a relationship so they don't have to
pay any bills
um but at the end of the day you're
supposed to be an adult right so you're
supposed to be able to um take care of
yourself
um so we push back on this whole 50 50
thing but without a man you'd have been
paying a hundred percent of those and
cooking with the airfryer and clean and
all those things it's like why do we you
know have 50 50 of such a big deal like
if we paying um half of the bills then
we can't respect the math you know
I was going to say that I think a lot a
lot of attitude comes with that with
that 50 50. I think women feel entitled
to
be able to control the household
my in my honest opinion I would like the
woman had an option so even if she
desires to work I think her having an
option is a different mindset but if a
man doesn't provide
eventually you're gonna see that tussle
when it comes to arguments when the
coins when it comes to back and forth
like she's going to feel like she has
one up because you can't 100 provide for
the household
I agree with that yeah why because it's
like okay so I think Austin was trying
to say or I'm sorry for getting anything
Jessica was trying to say like you know
you go out you work and then you come in
and take care of the house we're
assuming it's back in the days right
like no Roomba and air fryer movement
and it's like I can understand how I'm
draining it can be so you're going out
working as equal as your man and then
coming in and having to cook take care
of the kids and sexually please him
because you know yeah
like I understand where it can get
stressful so having the um option to
work as opposed to having to go out to
work because if I don't get up then the
light bill won't pay while my man is
like doing what but it's but it's
interesting because it's not like you
know it's like a lot of times I think we
want traditional outcomes but we're not
traditional women anymore how many of us
are 22 in virgins
you know
you
know what I mean like even when they
used to cook like they would make [ __ ]
from scratch you know like who who knows
how to make like a bunch of [ __ ] from
scratch nowadays it was a whole like
that's why Kevin Samuels would always
say like do you have a cookbook do they
have that in Brazil
and they make stuff from scratch yeah
just about everything
uh
they don't have air fryers
so in 2022 since we're not traditional
women anymore what do you think women
should bring to the table and what
should men bring to the table
women need to be peaceful in the United
States
are you saying we're not
you live in England right yeah I haven't
been here in the United States y'all are
not peaceful uh y'all want 50 50. I
don't want to do 50 50. I don't know how
to cook
peaceful Hawaii you shouldn't be
stressing me out I had a chick I was
paying 100 well let me say x I was
paying 100 of the bills for and I I
don't even want to talk too much about
it but it was annoying as hell living
with her and uh yeah y'all are not
peaceful so she wasn't like contributing
at all no she didn't do a damn thing
actually
not even wash the seat so yeah real lazy
as hell but
um
how long did she live with you six
months and then I got rid of her why'd
you keep her that long
that's a good question I knew after
three months it was time well yeah my
mom knew after three months because she
you know Mom said they had some sort of
energy or some [ __ ] like that she's like
oh the Lord is telling me you need to
get rid of it
seriously
did you talk about like uh household
stuff before you gotten had her move in
well she should have been doing this in
her in her mom's house and you should be
washing your own shoes I shouldn't have
to tell you that if you're not doing
nothing I shouldn't
she had to tell you to wash your sheets
and right
you should be more than happy till you
live in rent-free electric bill free
grocery free
I won't even wash the damn dishes no do
you think it's because she didn't know
like her role did you ask her to no
everybody knows how to wash dishes I
meant like know her role like you're
paying the bills what is she I reminded
her she didn't get the memo so that was
it was she really attractive is that why
she kind of got away and this one is the
worst yeah yeah so what would you rate
her one to ten like a nine like a nine
so you kind of let her get away with it
that's probably what did it yeah yeah
do you think if she what if she was like
a a six or a five you think you think
she's still
the ones that you're barely sexually
attracted to do the most and uh yeah
yeah they for sure they're on a
tightrope they can't get away with
nothing no I mean like do you think you
still you'd let them get away with it
one night it's like you get more
leverage based on it not anymore though
nobody
none nobody you learned your lesson
has that ever happened because you you
two are married
um so how familiar I don't know how long
you got you've been married for a while
oh you said you're in a relationship how
long have you been in a relationship
um it's fairly no fairly okay so you're
still familiar with the dating scene
yeah have you had any crazy stories like
that where like I don't know some girls
doing nothing for like what's what's
your modern dating story do you have any
uh
uh yeah
so I was dating this uh like realtor and
she didn't have any kids so
um and she was up there in age and and
the question that a lot of men always
asked is why is she single why is she
having the kids and so um but once you
start dating them you just start to see
different reasons as to why they are
single and not married so I just think
it was more of like a reality check like
she was always about her money it was to
the point where she was trying to sell
me [ __ ] you know and it's just like she
didn't know how to turn the sale off so
she trying to she was trying to like you
know a condo no just uh like it'd be
like the smallest things like hey like I
bought this uh this hat I can't fit it
um
you know would you want to buy it from
me and I'm just like why would I buy
like we're dating like why the hell
would I buy this [ __ ] from it it was
just the most craziest thing so uh I
start to see how and she was also
accounting my money as well she you know
she wanted to see what I was bringing to
her table so to speak so she was looking
at me to see what value I was to her so
I think the mindset is just different
what about what about you
so what's the question that I'm
answering you've been married 15 years
so how did you how are you familiar with
the dating scene like how do you even
know what's what's going on I talk to a
lot of crazy people so
conversations I get a chance to see
what's still going on I think the
biggest thing is that no no offense to
of course I love all the ladies but
women have to grow up yeah we've afford
the women to be be luxurious babies
that's it no good go to work be
independent make your own money but
being responsible a lot of women are
just not responsible and the cutest she
is the more she gets away with and I
think if we're gonna women are going to
bring something to the table with peace
be responsible be able to say I'm sorry
when you're wrong about something and
don't deflect and make it seem like the
man is doing something wrong right if
something goes wrong don't be the first
to point the finger sometimes look at
yourself I think it's maturity that a
lot of men particularly successful men
in this age you know cute ain't enough
anymore you gotta have some peace you've
got to have some maturity those are
things that I'm looking for can I play
Devil's Advocate okay okay go ahead
because the menu bad too
that was gonna be my next question so
yeah go ahead go ahead I mean I mean
socks for um women too especially if you
like more traditional minded and you
want that provider and protector guy a
lot of these men are sims no offense if
I can say that word
a lot of these men are like um loyalty
to their mama you know like
um they praise the woman and stuff and
it's like man up like you know do
something like yes there's like a simple
epidemic yeah it's like a lot of
feminists
and I mean I know we talk a lot about
the Modern Woman and we just like just
push the Modern Men to the side because
you know it's like do you think women I
feel like women created the Modern Men
though because we told them we wanted
them to open up to us we want to be
treated like Queens we hate the guys
that treat us like Queens it's kind of
like what comes first the chicken or the
egg because then the man allow us to be
too dominant or are way too dominant I
think it's because I think it's birth
control
I think birth control started everything
yes yeah Pearl's World I'd ban birth
control oh
yeah because if you look at the number
of women on birth control and the
divorce rate like the the chart is
really similar like it's like the more
women got on birth control so it's like
what started it the hose
that's my my opinion we would like to if
this is this is fascinating men will lie
too yeah we were told that women want a
sweet guy someone who can listen
someone who's empathetic well I do and
so what now we're giving women this and
women don't want this because we're
starting to see that there's a
differences between men and women yeah
and now women who raise this generation
of men they don't want the men that they
raise anymore I think we thought we
wanted it it's like because women we
don't know what we want because
you know Babyface song um I'll cook for
you as soon as I get home from work I'll
wash your clothes and a lot of men in
the 90s like fell for that so yeah I
agree okay so it's the women's fault I
just wanted to Circle back in my life
let's do that what do you guys think
well you've been quiet all right you've
been quiet what do you think do you
think what is your experience been with
Modern Men
um
well I have a really good boyfriend so
he's
um
but I think I've dated men in the past
that are Mama's boys and they're raised
a certain way and so they expect you to
be a certain way and usually I think a
lot of women now are really independent
and don't want to take care of like
the man like you're their mom so yeah I
guess in my past relationships I have
been the provider done all the things
that I thought that I was supposed to do
and now I'm just like ready to sit back
and not not do that and you want to have
the man
um
provide and be the leader and take care
of the
relationship as well do you think you
could do that even if you're splitting
at 50 50.
I think allowing myself to take off the
reins a little bit and give the man like
more responsibility I think
um I would be able to but splitting 50
50
um
I don't know sorry I got just like kind
of trained at that there but um yeah I
don't know having the man contribute
financially and then the home 50 50 it's
it's interesting
so it sounds like now
like so so no like it see it seems like
you'd only be able to submit in a way if
it wasn't 50 50.
yeah I think it's difficult if you've
never been in that situation to allow um
completely to take off and just let the
man provide 100 I've never had that so
I'm not sure
so is it that you can't do it now
currently
I just haven't been in a position
too yeah I've always provided yeah okay
and I think I come from a very strong
relationship with my mother who was the
Sole Provider and so I I've always seen
that so I'm just expected in my own mind
okay maybe I'm supposed to be the
provider and like
yeah well I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you firsthand you might want to
test it because uh I think that your
mother raised you and I've been in a
situation where the mother had a heavy
influence on the woman yeah and it
didn't play well because it just wrote
the relationship the wrong way because
I'm pretty sure there's some other areas
within the relationship that may have
some struggles because of that right
yeah absolutely yeah
and to add to that as well like uh you
you'll be you'll find that you're more
peaceful when you've got a guy taking
care of you like I tell women this all
the time it's not so it's not hard to
get a man who provides for you you just
have to be a woman who can appreciate
that right and you can't allow fear that
he's gonna have control you know that's
the term he's uncontrolling right it's
gonna control you you got to be able to
to know that your God got your best
interest at heart and that whatever he
does is for the best for you both and
the rest of that it's not there are guys
out here who want that it's just a lot
of women there's a level of distrust and
that that won't allow you to embrace and
just rest in your femininity right but
y'all are there being somebody's mama so
yeah
right what being somebody's mama oh no I
don't want to yeah so yeah so you can't
get 100 man
okay what you can't get 100 man
100 man like this for Friday
provider yeah I would love to make you
you're gonna no you just said you
wouldn't
okay maybe I misunderstood
I give you a couple of years well I
think it's because earlier you said you
should have a backup plan
but like if you're if you have a guy
that's providing you don't have a backup
plan so I think he's saying like you
said you would love that but you also
said you wouldn't okay you said you
didn't want to be his mom either so
that's what I'm saying
yeah no I guess in my past relationships
I have been the mom I have you know done
a lot of things in the home and it's
hard I love moms yeah I think you guys
would have to having two different
definitions of the mom yeah maybe so
yeah maybe so I think you're thinking
off more like the nurturing no I'm
saying that's what modern women call it
uh you know Housewives
call it being a Slave yeah or a slave
yeah that [ __ ] gets on my nerves
I just want to make a point as well so a
lot of ladies say that they want the man
to be providers and I think that you
should but don't underestimate women
provide it as well you are providers of
something so we talked about the home
and peace and things you provide that as
well
um and just like you say you don't want
to take care of a man think about think
about how this sounds like I want a man
and pay all the bills you know protect
me provide for me love me nurture me
you know what I mean so the trade-off is
to give him what he wants and sometimes
what we call being his mama is really
you just being nurturing you know what I
mean and I think women got to be okay
with nurturing their man
that's what do you guys think the
difference is between being nurturing
too like to him like do you think what
he's saying is true I think the
difference between being his mom is like
making decisions for him telling him
what to do
because maybe that was the situation you
were in like you had to make the
decision you were the head like what do
you what do you want to do and he's like
I don't know
yeah very passive yeah they can't make a
decision to save his life yeah that's
the worst
yeah what do you think I think that
makes sense but there's a flips out to
that so a lot of a lot of times you
think guys are indecisive really they've
been raised by Mamas and so they want to
make you happy so it's what were you
where do you want to go what do you want
to do and that's their way of trying to
please you so it looks like it's
weakness but it's really I'm just trying
to please you I wonder if like you were
like do you feel like with those guys if
you're direct with them and say like I
want you to make decisions that they
would like listen or no
I think men like women that are
assertive and like know what they want
and can make that decision like yes
Brian
do you like women that are assertive I
mean yes yeah I don't like indecisive
women yeah there's no Clarity in the
United States no that's the word Clarity
yeah yeah I don't have clarity
do you like a woman to tell you what to
do no you're not gonna tell me what to
do
so you don't really like no Clarity
means that you know what the hell you
want to do but you're not about to tell
me what to do uh so not not necessarily
depending on you for every decision in
my life but also not controlling your
life
no wait what do you repeat that so I'm
not I
decisive in
muscle nuts well I'm just talking about
in between us I need you to have Clarity
you know some a lot of women don't know
what they want to do with who they're
talking to oh oh okay but can I have an
example
for example if you get a chick's number
she doesn't know what she wants to do
with you after that
okay yeah there's a lot of texting games
I don't play games
so
just like she doesn't know if she wants
to hang because I'm just imagining you
get a girl's number you ask her on a
date she says yes or no that's what you
would think
how does it okay how does it go well
usually I have to play with you for like
two weeks or something like that and if
I I can't win I come off Direct that's
the problem if I'm trying to play it out
that's another problem I go to Brazil
it's a complete flute
[Laughter]
can you give another example where it
happens further along in a relationship
further along
give me an example of what you want me
to give an example of well meaning like
you said that she's unsure she doesn't
know what she wants so give me an
example of like where you would see that
for the long relationship to make you
question it has to it could be within a
month or two because I'm just maybe you
didn't see it on the front end but then
it's like uh I've had a chick that when
we first met she claimed she had just
got a relationship so she said she
didn't want us to have a relationship
for six months and then I flew her out
here and when she gets back she's like
We're exclusive now I was like no we're
not you said six months has been two and
a half and that now she wants to cut me
off I don't care
I'm thinking you asking women not to be
decisive is like asking water not to be
wet that's just like women not to be
decisive yeah like or to be decisive
like women are indecisive even if you
look at like feminine traits indecisive
this is a feminine trait is a problem
when you're indecisive where it
sabotages everything yeah I agree yeah
yeah
I can decide you know if you don't know
where you want to go out to eat that's
fine but yeah if you don't know if you
want to [ __ ] with me or not that's not
gonna that's not gonna fly I'm not
dealing with it do you would you guys
prefer a guy that's a provider or a
protector
a provider provider provider
a little bit of both a little yeah a
little bit but I think if I had to
choose
um
a protector I would pick protect I'm
like surprised you say provide like I
would protector over everything I think
it's because I come from a family of all
men all my my cousins and you know stuff
are men and so I've always had so much
uh male uh contributions and feeling
protected from family that I'm like man
I don't I don't want that completely
with my with my partner I feel like I
have it enough with my my family so I
prefer I mean just in the are the guys
are the guys you typically pick
providers because it sounds like the
guys you pick typically you said you
like paid more so it sounds like no I
said we were 50 50. so as always
um my last relationship we both were
contributing
um the same financially okay why are you
laughing yeah I was laughing
why are you laughing because because
because it's like so so how I think of
it maybe because I don't come from a
family of a lot of men but it's like
um I would much rather my man protect me
and my family my kids from danger and
then we can figure out the provide the
provision part of it and um it's more
than just financially provided you know
it's like there are other things he can
provide like his protection
um so to to to to to just I feel like
like we like we use men as as wallets
and ATMs and stuff and we don't think
other things that they you know they
contribute to the relationship and then
I'm thinking of I have my kids and I'm
like like someone is breaking in and
then my husband nudging me because he's
not a protector to go downstairs and do
hell no
I'm just thinking like I feel like the
most genuine relationships are when he's
a protector because if you visit the
provider like wouldn't you say like
you'd just be gone if the money's gone
yeah yes yeah you can disagree it's okay
like I'm just curious I agree
would I be gone if the money was gone
like I just feel like the girls that are
down for if you're a protector like
they're down for the ups and the Downs
like through it all but if you're there
because he's a provider like I would
just think the money goes you're gone
too
I mean ideally I would want both yeah
you know but I think I think also if
he's a protector he's going to want to
protect us from being evicted and I've
been on the streets like he's gonna want
to provide
what do you what do you think
like she said I really think he'll
protect you from being homeless yeah
yeah what is your experience do you
think women like prefer guys that
protect or provide if they're the pick
I would say Protect protect yeah pretty
I see provide why
um most women
typically say they have people that
protect them a lot of women can't say
that they've had a man that provides for
them and I see it differently I think a
man who's willing to go work for his
woman and take care of her that takes a
level of fierceness to to take care of
your life in another life as well if you
guys have kids and those those kind of
men when you work for something you're
fierce in protecting that and so I think
I think I think from what I've seen
women want providers because you're not
going to be fighting every day and if if
you if this is a fear my provision is
going to put us in a different zip code
so that this isn't a problem and if I
need to be with some security I can pay
for that as well you see what I'm saying
so I think it's the mindset when it
comes to the provider I find that the
older women are they tend to say
provider more yeah yeah because I I
asked a couple girls on my last like
trip and they were like in their mid-30s
and they said provider because like the
world's pretty safe today yeah yeah
that's what the police are for right
that's the way it's the system that's
playing the place I'm sorry because like
so
Sony first moved into my apartment so
I know it was like it's like kind of in
the hood like the gentrifications you
know it's on the border and like I
called the cops and they're like oh is
he still there and I was like No And the
cops gonna come but if I had a man at
the time I know he would have been there
you know so it's like yeah you said
that's what the cops are for and the
world is safe gone not for me personally
you have a gun or no no we're in Texas I
just assumed I just assume everyone's
got one
but oh my God that's so scary did like
did
like did he try to chew again or did you
go so my apartment is brand new right
um at the time when I moved in a couple
years ago so it was like um a lot of the
apartments were empty so it was one of
the homeless man was trying to see which
one is empty and I had just moved in
like I was literally like moving my
things from the Cars I was going back
and forth and luckily I had locked the
door and as I was reaching for the
handle I saw it moved and I called the
cops in a [ __ ] they don't lock the
empty Apartments
because it was like brand new it was
still Construction
like are you mad I was scared I would be
I'd be terrified and then they just
never came never came that's so mad to
me they didn't want to see who's trying
to break into your because they're like
oh is he still there and it was like No
And they were like oh what if they came
back
they want to get like security footage
or nothing
no no no no no I don't care
uh let me see
oh we were talking about you guys think
hypergamy is a bad thing
I think it's a great thing you think
it's a great thing why oh my parking me
has wait actually I'm sorry I'm gonna
say you guys didn't know the definition
of hypergamy earlier I'm gonna say it
and I'm Gonna Let You Go Okay the
definition of hypergamy is the action of
marrying or forming a sexual
relationship with a person of a superior
sociological or educational background
so go ahead sorry yeah I think that
women um because you guys have wombs so
I think it's women have to be strategic
because you mess up that you mess up you
really mess up your dating options right
so and then a woman's hypergamy has the
ability to inspire her man to become
greater and so for that reason I think
hypergamy is absolutely fantastic what
about women that make a lot of money and
they feel like they need to date up do
you think it's still okay there what do
we mean by data just in terms of money
money-wise yeah
I don't know I I'm not sure something
like what if you make what's the
significant amount amount of money let's
say six figures I mean like one of the
stats they use is like women with a doc
like doctoral degree or the most single
so yeah and so and so the way that I
look at that is if you if you earn a
salary of twenty to fifty thousand
dollars but you're like five hundred
thousand dollars in debt well that
you're not doing No One's Gonna do
anything right yeah so to me if if we
just judge this by money then that's one
thing be with a man though that's
confident and secure with themselves
that it can provide a lifestyle that you
guys can be happy with and go with that
because at the end of the day money that
stuff can change okay you think
hypergamy is a bad thing no it's
actually great that women want the best
DNA they can get and the best result for
their life but it's just on steroids too
much in the United States okay yeah
y'all are very unrealistic I love that
you put in the United States
there's a difference there's a
difference it's been to Brazil he knows
it
ah
hypergamy is it a bad thing no I think
it's a good thing and I actually like
what uh Sergio said too that it does
inspire man because with men know and
understand that there's competition out
here it just makes them be a little bit
more competitive
what about you guys yeah I think it's a
great thing and once you've had that
once
um I think it's hard to go back had what
once had hypogly had somebody that was
um financially stable who was Superior
than you I think I don't know if it
creates a block but in my mind it's hard
to go to date down
do you do you think so are you saying if
you had like an ex-boyfriend that made
say 75 000 it would be hard to go down
from that something like that I think
yeah once you have experienced a type of
Lifestyle it is it is difficult do you
think it's the same thing with like a
few let's say you had one boyfriend that
made 75 000 and then you had another
boyfriend that maybe he was six two like
would you say it's it's each trait like
the best in them is hard to go down from
yeah I think most of relationships that
I've been in I always try to take the
best part of that person and I'm gonna
not gonna lie I do try to look for that
in another person I try not to compare
relationships or men
um but there are certain qualities that
if I've had it I'm like okay I'm not
gonna I'm sorry I'm not gonna date to a
five five foot person when I've
experienced a six foot
maybe it's I'm being unrealistic but
that's my well yeah my experience
that was an extreme example okay but
there's not that many fast food I'll
give a couple inches
down anymore
would you guys say that makes it like
understandable why a guy doesn't want a
girl that's like been with a lot of guys
because because like there's more that
we would compare it to yes yeah
yeah
it's interesting like most girls when I
ask them this they're like no
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah
well if they're just using her as a
whole yeah
what about you
um yeah hypergamy is a good thing I
think though with social media you know
dating apps and stuff we don't know when
to satisfy like what we have so we're
always looking for the next best thing
um and to to your point yeah it's
definitely hard to date someone who is
tall you know you could wear your heels
and then
you know
you can't but then it's also like you
have to as you said you know pick out
the best things in the relationship and
look for it what I had a question if I
had
um since we're talking about have part
of me do you think that in a
relationship
and or somebody that's married do you
think the woman ever shuts off
as far as looking for a high performance
man like if she finds one at that time
like there's a man just I got him cool
but does she still keep looking low key
behind the scenes I think that's why
it's important for men to always try to
to
um level up like always try to be
um on that purse you are doing better
because then if I say we got together
and you know you made like I don't know
50k a year and then in two years you're
making like 75k that's still technically
High pergament because I'm I'm with the
same guy but you know different status
okay so basically no no I'm looking at
the same guy
but like different like he's Improvement
but if you stayed at that 50 000 then
it's going to be a problem eventually no
yes I think I will be honest yeah I
think it's no good problem
I mean you got it yeah
I know it's a little bit but as it says
75 right and you're interested
introduced into that lifestyle at the 75
okay you guys are living if he stays if
he stays at 75k in the life just stays
the same I think that you're gonna go
looking around especially if you're not
married but I think even women that I
married still looking around and they
low-key comparing
looking at their husbands like you know
why is this person this person like he's
doing this so it is important for men to
always level up as you said because this
man it's a competition out here like I
think that's just how men and women are
wired a certain way and I think women
are going to always be looking
yeah do you think men are hypergamous
too
somebody asking this question
earlier I'll let y'all go first the
homosexuals are but regular masculine
men absolutely not no no I'm not talking
about for money so like like like I
would say money to women's looks to them
well see we can't mention those
typically I can invest money and grow it
I can't invest looks right so so
typically men are not hypergamous we
want a decent woman and if you happen to
be Stellar especially after you get 30.
when you get 20s and stuff you want the
best looks you want what you want as you
get older you get more established I
would rather have a seven six seven wife
who is loyal who's faithful who who's
inspiring then to have a dime and I
can't rely on her so I think it changes
as you get older it's not a stranger
I've heard that from guys because when I
ask guys like the questions of like what
how attractive a girl has to be and that
sort of thing their answers seem to
differ in their 20s than their 30s
would you what do you think I'm
hypergamous yeah I mean you had the
nines
no I mean a little bit because she got
away with more because she was hotter
yeah no that's because I was younger oh
okay yeah okay no I know better now you
said you wouldn't let a six get away
with it huh you said you wouldn't let a
six get away with what you got away with
yeah never at any point in my life would
that ever be a thing I'm not pregnant
myself because I went to Brazil
so you you think
um because you can get all what you what
he just described in that country
okay where are you gonna bring one back
no I'm going there oh you're gonna move
there he's not coming in a few days oh
shut up you're at you're literally
leaving the country yeah oh my God I did
not know that that's crazy
with the United States you're real upset
with the United States yeah what's
what's tell me the difference between
Brazilian and American women oh I did a
video on this
I can't believe wow you said in two days
they have Clarity okay they're usually
more fit okay they don't argue that does
not mean they don't have an opinion like
I could see that I saw it just because
you don't have to being submissive does
not mean being a slave or she doesn't
have a say-so but we don't argue about
everything American women typically not
all of them but typically they got to be
careful with my words so I I I'm with
you typically argue a lot
I think everything is just the opposite
everything is the opposite it's a needle
in the haystack you were born in the U.S
right yes do you ever think that a
Brazilian woman is just trying to submit
to get a citizenship here we go
I lived in Miami and there's a lot of
you know South American women that do do
that and well they're in America but but
they don't want to come here not the
majority of them oops I did an interview
yesterday and they all say they would
rather live in Brazil okay or somewhere
else not the United States so yeah maybe
just
says definitely a cultural difference
they're beautiful there too yeah like
all the Brazil all the Brazilian nannies
I had were literally
that's not how programming yeah
no because I mean a lot of girls will
say it's like extreme but I kind of get
it but like it just just because I think
in the U.S like men value Purity youth
but in the US the average age of first
marriage Roman is like 28 like how pure
and Youthful are you at 28. hmm
you agree disagree I don't really think
about marriage that much right now so I
don't know I didn't even understand go
to ask me the question again uh
uh no I was just saying like I unders
like a lot of girls think it's extreme
to like move for that oh for women but I
I kind of guess it's a shaming day they
always
it's not extreme
she had mentioned something you said
it's culturally they're different yeah
do you find that it's like so it's
American culture that you have American
culture is dumb yes
my personality is not for the United
States now okay
is every man qualified to lead
no no what makes a man qualified to lead
if he's assertive he's a good decision
maker he's a great Problem Solver like
you know he's a great protector leader
provider I think some men's personality
like the alphas of the world are just
mental lead and I know some betas that
are just
quiet not uh extroverted not don't have
those leadership qualities I think there
are two separate pools of men that that
just don't have those Alpha qualities
not necessarily that it's a bad thing
it's not something I would personally
want but you know not all men are meant
to be that strong leader and maybe they
do maybe they are Mama's Boys in need
those strong women I don't know
I think this is a good question so now I
may know a kennel man with the right
mentorship yes and this is it's three
simple things it's he's sure himself
he's sure of where he's going he can
Inspire others to see that Vision if
they can do those things then he can
catalyze anybody to follow up so that's
a really good definition yeah I would
agree with it yeah like they summed it
up yeah he stole it yeah it's like the
question is what do women do because
there's only so many Alphas or men that
can lead so what are women supposed to
do some of y'all need to know y'all's
place and not everybody can get there
now I was about to say it man absolutely
yeah that's the problem that Kevin
Samuel show so wait let me ask the
question because this I hate this Alpha
and beta talk
um how are we defining Alpha like
amongst men or Alpha amongst men and
women
I would say both
yeah because then technically then and
and hear me also technically wouldn't
every man be an alpha compared to a
woman but he's just not an alpha
compared to other men
well she Compares them as an alpha
amongst the other men so so then he he's
capable of leading her but he's not
married
yeah but the but the problem is even
when you guys were saying earlier like
the majority of what percent of men are
really leading their women
you know it's a complex question because
like men can see men as an alpha and
women I see that man as an alpha yeah
and being loud and void that doesn't
make you illegal you know there's quiet
men who can lead like some of the most
you know wealthy men you don't hear them
anywhere but they are the effectively
the leader so I think is is what you
Dean is that alpha or that beta I think
it just depends on perspective yeah but
I mean at the end of the day women only
want 20 of men
but isn't a cat a beta be a great
husband absolutely yeah yeah
no beta cannot be a great husband
because he's not sure of himself that's
that's why he's Veda like a man who's
not sure of himself and who can be
controlled or manipulated by a woman
he's going to be a terrible husband
because women are chaotic and very
indecisive and he's going to try to make
you happy in your indecision he's going
to be unstable he's not sure of himself
and he is incapable of being a good
husband
only want that that yeah but that only
lasts for so long exactly yeah those
women hate their husbands though you
don't talk about women she can control
everybody's like seeing the the pool boy
or something on the side
know
but it's just it still begs the question
like what do what do women do right
because we say hypergamy is a good thing
right but at the same time like women
only want 20 of men
so do you think the the option is they
lower their standards or they share
those
people yeah the majority y'all need a
little yesterday
well I mean everybody's not beautiful
everybody doesn't qualify for the top
left top man unless you want to share
I mean he'll smash anybody yeah
I say ladies keep what you want go buy a
bullet and got to get your nice mattress
because you're gonna be living by
yourself keep what you want right and
let the women who are qualified go for
the men that they can get and have them
that's what I say and so you think the
the other woman should just die alone
okay okay
[Laughter]
so answer that question I'm gonna say we
might have to lower these standings I
mean you have to
think if you're single and it's been
this way for so long you got to try
something different you can't you can't
keep upholding that that mentality that
lifestyle that you live in because it's
not giving you nowhere so you have to
lower your standards
um you got the rest until like your
femininity and and just try to see where
it gets you
see the problem with that Jr is I'm
concerned with is if you tell women to
lower the standards she's going to show
that man she lowered her she's gonna
make him feel like she lowered her
standards it's going to be a terrible
thing for her so in my I agree with me
to adjust their standards because if you
get into your mind that you settled that
man's gonna feel that and as soon as you
get a whiff of another dude that that
you think that you could have you're
gonna be you're going to resent your man
and if the opportunity to present
yourself you're going to cheat on them
right so I'll tell you women adjust
yourself and be realistic about you
because a lot of women want stuff that
they don't qualify for hey sorry but if
you adjust Lord however you want to chop
it up it's still a possibility yeah you
know we're just giving some factual
advice from a man's perspective on what
you need to do so until that woman makes
the decision as far as if she's going to
do that
you can say uh being a little bit adjust
lower she's got to change that mindset I
agree would you guys rather like share a
guy that you really like or stay with a
guy that you kind of like
and he's not faithful but he's like okay
you kind of like him or get or share a
guy that you really really like you're
sharing the guys that they like right
now
wait why don't I really like him
so how many things you want in a guy
what what are your what are your
standards how many things you want
I'm I'm five five things okay he has
what should we give him two what do you
guys think two of them two out of the
five it's a little low well should we
give them three three okay one guy has
three out of the five things you want
one guy has five out of the five things
you want
I'll go with a three out of the five but
three out of five yeah okay and you
wouldn't that was sorry to not share
them so not sure yeah I think I agree
with you completely yeah I don't want to
share it yeah I don't want to share
what are what are the five things I'm
curious
um assertive masculine oh it goes okay
yeah I get it yeah
um a great leader provider protector
okay so
um five five and feminine five five yeah
I took out two you said five three I
forgot you're sharing him yeah
and it's not it's not even the five five
part it's the feminine part I don't want
a feminine yes but but so it's kind of
cap you know what I mean like yeah I I
think it's like that fun but I think
most girls would rather show the guy
they like
yeah I'd rather share them exactly
[Laughter]
[Music]
sure do you think most women have backup
plans
yes yes
and their DMs
oh you're talking about guys
yeah like in your relationship yeah
she's like I gotta switch
and then I'm like a backup plan no no I
mean like a backup plan as a guy yeah I
think it depends on who you're in a
relationship with I've had backup plans
in the past I don't currently have a
backup plan so so it depends how she
views the guy yeah yeah
at least that's honest
women don't need a backup plan y'all get
approached everywhere yeah I have plenty
of
options
yeah we got approachable who are we
getting approach you getting approached
by somebody you like at some point all
you gotta do is go to the grocery store
I think men underestimate so much
masculinity to Israel in this Society do
you guys how often do you guys get
approached
in person
not always by the best approaches but at
least like once every two weeks once
every two weeks
I mean I don't go to the clubs here we
go it doesn't have to be a club you can
walk down the sidewalk
translation means that she's interested
how many dudes walk up to you and flirt
with you is it daily
pretty often but not but again by people
that I'm interested in
actually give my phone
oh you need to understand no I'm just
kidding I need a provider okay okay
no but I do agree with you most people
most a lot of women that are good
looking attractive have you know their
life together you do get approached
pretty often especially living in a big
cities even average ones and below
average they can approach huh I just
find them like guys don't approach in
person as much it's a waste of time now
yeah no I understand why but I'm just
saying like not in Brazil
seriously Brazil needs to hire you yeah
what percent of girls that you approach
in Brazil I get 80 of the women I
approach what would you say in the U.S
yeah
like 10 to 20.
10 to 20. yeah it's a day and night are
the are the are the men there like is it
because they're cap in England
I think the men are better looking and
the girls are uglier so it's like kind
of like do you think the men are less
good looking in Brazil no you have some
competition there okay but uh women like
to pretend they'll give you a choosing
signal here and you go approach them and
act like they didn't know why you came
over there and I'm like dude I know I'm
not [ __ ] crazy you look at everybody
like that you know
yeah that's why it's 20 so
20
um
do you think men have a backup plan too
not the majority of men no do you think
the men that can have a backup plan yes
yeah
it depends on where you are what stage
you are yeah like most if you are
focused on your business you just ain't
got time for it yeah you really just
don't have time so either you're gonna
be my girl or you ain't gonna be my girl
that's really that's really what it is
if I if if I see men who have backup
plans a lot of them there's something
he's afraid of he's insecure about
something and he's got to keep these
options because he might he might lose
them me who know they can go out and go
get what they want
there's no need for backup yeah you so
you think the ones that are more
insecure in their relationship
I think so maybe it's more of like a
she likes him for the money type stuff
um it could be a lot of different things
um it could be like he's outgrowner like
let's say they met when they were really
young and he's expanded himself and she
stayed the same and you know it just
could be it could be a number of
different reasons
oh I actually have a question what do
you guys think about women that gain a
bunch of weight in a relationship
or lose a bunch of weight yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh she's she's in last place now
she's not there's no kind of she's lost
the competition so she's more likely to
be cheated at all she's more likely to
get cheated on yes
do you think men will like should leave
if she gains a bunch of weight
and if she's like beared kids for you or
whatever is it are they married or yeah
no but he may cheat
and she should be able to understand it
yeah
I don't think a woman should ever live
over yourself
no yeah I agree I think you should put
in as much work I mean at least a
healthy eat healthy want to work out for
your man and also like do small things
to keep that relationship alive and I
think it should be for both ways like I
don't want my man getting too
comfortable and getting thick like every
once in a while during the holidays okay
but you know like to keep that sex alive
I think it's really important on both
parties to to put in that work it's not
part of me it's common though isn't it
like I see girls get a ring all the time
and just blow up yeah you know it is
common I think yeah yeah too I think
it's very important for you to try to
maintain your frame when you even just
improve even just improve so I wouldn't
say it's grounds for cheating but a
conversation needs to happen but now if
she doesn't want to improve well she
doesn't want to change but she's giving
you pushback then
I think a deeper conversation might
might have to happen I should have the
same perspective and for a couple
reasons if you've got kids however the
mama eats that's how the kids are going
to eat so if Mama's unhealthy then the
kids will be as well that's what I said
I I go as far I think it's like child
abuse if you're gonna have your kid be
obese yeah like you're putting that kid
at every statistical
I don't know I think that's really wrong
I'd say it's more I want I don't want to
say it's more important but especially
young mama has to not you have kids you
don't gain a little bit of weight this
pandemic people right you do what you do
so it's not grounds to walk away
especially in the word that you use she
bore children that just put a whole
different level of sentiment on it she's
got your kids but at some point she's
got to be healthy because if Mama's not
gonna be then the family won't be yeah I
think also too people need to understand
um
like the
if you look at grandmother especially
within the black community
um and she from the shop she cooked a
certain way and so that just keeps
passing on and on at some point in time
it's up to us to do the research which I
think a lot of us have been and
sometimes you get pushed back because
they don't want to change it's all they
know it's uncomfortable for them to be
able to learn how to cook things outside
of their comfort zone where they say
things are nasty and that's why I always
push for parents to start giving their
kids water at an early age and veggies
they don't have to be nasty but you've
been saying this nasty so the kids are
gonna think it's nasty but if you if you
find if you see a light where there
where you guys can improve within the
family
then go ahead and bring it up and it
should give you push back that might be
a ground stuff for a deeper conversation
too because if you're trying to better
the family and the health of the family
why would you push back
it seems like a lot of women will take
it personal like I've heard from a lot
of guys that they can't like talk to
their girls about that stuff because
they get offended yeah they look at
everything like it's control the Earth's
like an attack on them like you don't
find me attractive anymore right yeah I
think that's the insecurity
I mean anything that makes sense it
makes sense to eat healthier like I also
want to become vegan like and I did it
for six months but I just want to just
leave vegan yeah oh God I could not do
vegan I mean that's what I'm leaning
towards I mean I just recently had food
poison a couple days ago and I was just
like what the hell are they now granted
it couldn't have came from me it was at
a kitchen the cocktails oh but
[Laughter]
[Music]
let me get back on track
all right well we'll go ahead and move
on
oh actually I saw this question on a
different podcast
all right a man's dating to woman he
lies to one and is truthful to the other
which relationship does he value more
the one he lies to really yeah
uh I think if he's really valuing that
relationship he's trying to keep it
secure and like trying to make sure he
does everything within his realm to to
save that relationship and I think
somebody who's more open with he doesn't
really care about as much maybe I've
never thought about it that way yeah you
lie to keep it and you tell the truth
because you don't give a damn yeah yeah
but can't you also tell the truth
because you and that person have like
like yeah yeah great relationship that
you're like hey it depends on what I'm
telling the truth about
it's about the other relationship right
is that what you were getting at
just saying
the point is as he
says he loves her is he does he lie to
her I think that's the point it's not
the two yeah yeah I love you if I like
his you know otherwise I mean why not
but it's interesting I feel like men are
more straightforward than women though
as you should be yeah
what do you think do you do you lie to
your wife or tell her the truth
[Applause]
it's actually a really good I've never
thought about that I honestly don't know
like if she said she says do I look fat
in this dress and she does you telling
her I do
But but so my thing is I want it to be
better so so let me give you like some
real truth I've got people in my family
that passed away because of of weight
yeah so that to me is I'm serious about
that so I would absolutely be honest of
course in a kind way but absolutely be
honest what if she said okay I saw you
flirting with her were you flirting with
that girl and you were you telling her
the truth 100 denied
she talked to me
what about you
um
a man okay okay let me read it um a man
is dating two women he lies to one and
is truthful to the other which
relationship does he value more I'm
gonna say that it's one of those things
that's situational okay
um I think that you have some instance
where you may
want to protect somebody that you love
as you said
um and then there's other reasons where
you probably don't care so but
ultimately I think the truth is where it
should be across the board but I but I
think somebody would have somebody that
lies all the time will have to grow and
understand like the power of what truth
does but that has been situations where
uh men and women have lied because
they may not want to hurt the other
person but they may want to try to keep
the other person so what about the
situation girls you were flirting with a
girl she says um did I see you flirting
with that girl at the store what's she
saying
now I can save this it was harmless
because I mean men and women flirt all
the time
um and I think that we're moving into
the direction where people just be
upfront I mean it's I mean they want me
to go to the movies and
um I don't know what some of the man you
guys seen over in the movies and you
sliding down you see like oh are you
just helping okay that's for you
I mean that's considered like a flirt
right but it's it's not in person but
you guys are lusting over someone so I
just think it's just the nature of uh
men and women it's just a matter of you
can control it would you guys rather be
have someone be honest with you or lie
to you
honest honest yeah I want somebody
that's honest with me I want both of us
to like grow you don't want someone to
be honest
ly
from the truth they didn't tell me but
if it's gonna like especially if it's
something harmless lied to me because
then I'm gonna be stuck on it and then
now I'm gonna be insecure about it and
you can never go back to that grocery
store yeah because what if he says yeah
she was bad as hell
yeah
I'd rather just like not
no you but you'd rather he'd be like
straight up with that yeah I just I want
us to both grow like you were saying
that you do in your relationship I want
somebody to be honest with me if I have
a booger in my nose if I look crazy like
I want I want my uh partner to tell me
to you know go and change and stuff like
that
yeah I don't know I just think like
there's some things as a girl like we
don't really want to know
do you know an example
the flirting yeah you know and I I think
like I I think a lot of times like we
think we can handle the truth but then
we get it and we get mad or we get
insecure like we'll think about it for a
week when you know like one time like my
ex-boyfriend he he looked at me and he's
just like you are annoying the [ __ ] out
of me right now because I like I was
trying to talk to him when he got home
or whatever and I remember being like Oh
my God and I was thinking and I I
probably should have you know just let
him like because guys want to chill when
they get home they don't want to like
talk to you yeah but it's still like did
I do you really want that brutal honesty
on a regular basis what was it the way
he said it or just the fact that he said
it Ah that's probably the way he said it
but
I'm just thinking like if guys really
did had no filter and just said
everything they wanted to say I feel
like I would get my feelings hurt I mean
I think that uh again I've learned a lot
and especially within the past uh like a
couple years just being in certain
situations that
the truth is the way to go you know and
um
if you're in a relationship I think you
should have open communication and men
should be able to set the foundation to
voice what it is that that they wanted
what they like because how else is she
gonna know to improve if he's not saying
anything you know I mean I don't
disagree it's just like I I feel like if
guys gave us unfiltered honesty I just
don't think most of us could take it but
actually want it I think that's where
the problem is yeah so men want to be
honest but a lot of women just can't you
can't handle it yeah a lot of women just
can't take it right yeah but if you've
dated before I'm sure you've heard baby
tell me the truth I won't get mad you're
like oh no you take me you said you
won't get mad and as soon as I kill you
right so so it's not just us being able
to talk like because we need to we want
yeah but can a woman hear us and receive
it without making it worse yeah more
than what it is and it's like I want to
be like yeah I can take it but I'm just
like being honest I'm like nah I don't
think I want to know every single like I
think there's some things I'd just
rather be like lied to about and it
depends on the situation because if I'm
getting fat tell me I'm
but if it's like you're flirting with a
girl don't tell me that I don't want to
know that do you guys want to know if he
cheats just one time you want to know no
no would you rather just like live in
okay hide it what if he has a side chick
you want to know
yeah I want it in the relationship
immediately
I'm calling cap on all these beautiful
women they the only way that they
wouldn't care is if they if it's
hypergament that he's way ahead of him
if it's 50 50 they want to know about it
and this dude is going to hear he's
gonna hear for the rest of the
relationship
ladies I'm a lion
that's if she doesn't leave yep I
wouldn't know you would stay no I would
leave oh you would leave but if I don't
know I won't I just don't want to know
then
because if I don't find out if you're
gonna yeah just cheating does cheating
hurt you if you never find out yeah
exactly but I think he'll continue to do
it
we never found out exactly what about
guys does body count matter if you never
find out
and even if you got a hand of you
getting the truth you still have a link
is the truth so it just don't don't even
bother asking if you like her for
whatever reason then just go ahead and
go with it because you might get your
feelings hurt that's what I've heard
from most guys it's like they just don't
even want to know I mean at that point
now it's a different story if you're out
there walking around and you got a
couple guys every now and then in the
same city like yeah
who's that guy
makes the [ __ ]
let me Smash If you keep hearing that
[ __ ] then it's like oh now you've been
forced into knowing the body count but
most women are not going to tell you
the truth I don't want another body
count I'm never gonna ask yeah it's
never a number you want to hear
it what if it's zero I don't want to
hear that either because that's not true
I mean she could be like a 20 year old
you know I've had a 29 year old chick
tell me she had only had sex with two
people and not to this day I find that
hard to believe
she looks good too so no
um I got mad at 19. so
um so it's it's a little different for
me when we met each other we were each
other so it's a little different but
what about like like I'm sure you have
friends you hear stories I tell them you
should know about this okay like there
was nothing worse than a guy you know
you hey guys he got my girl guess I want
to introduce you and your boy's like oh
that's your girl right there's nothing
worse than that so yeah especially if
you guys are in the same city you got to
know these things because you don't want
to be no man wants to be embarrassed nor
that they're running out of the man
gonna smash that girl so to me it's very
it's very important what do you think
guys can get the truth from girls
you can look at behaviors
but if she's on like she's on Instagram
and everything is always out or she's
always got some random messages and
stuff you kind of look at behaviors and
even if she hasn't done that she's
presented herself like she is and that
to me that's that's still as bad as well
I have a question that's a good point
what if a girl with a low body count and
you believe her she has a low body count
but she's over sexualizing herself on
social media is that the same thing or
would you like let that pass I still
think she's lying
yeah
yeah
if it was I would say it's some type of
insecurity there that's the reason why
that yeah but as to why she's why she's
so much man I have a high body count but
I think it's it's something do you find
I mean most of the girls that I know
that sexualize themselves on social
media they do sleep around do you find
that's not the case
oh I don't know no okay you don't know
anyone that does that so I'm always on
volleyball teams like there's always one
like
women like attention so
so not necessarily I don't necessarily
have to be give up the trials and again
we will never know if they are but I
think women like attention like to seek
the validation especially with social
media being out there
everybody wants to follow the followers
and the likes
what do you guys think do you think guys
can find out about that stuff or no you
think it's like worth their time to ask
I feel like it does nothing I'm gonna
add this too real quick I think it's a
it could be insecurity on the man's part
too and I think women May view that as
an insecurity so why are you concerned I
mean just imagine you asking about every
little thing who's
who are you texting
who's all the guys in your DM how many
people you want to smash it's just like
a pattern that just don't even ask don't
need about it don't even matter no other
man should matter if you're in the
picture
and if you if you focus on everything
else that she got going on then she
gonna view you a certain type of way but
what if she's a 304
I guess you're gonna have to you're
gonna have to vet and analyze that at
that point I mean I don't think 304 just
got it walking around with a 304 knee
I'm gonna hit so I think you're gonna
have to
split together the context clues without
accent with all accent
with all
apps you just have to observe her
behavior yeah because you because you'll
never know
um and and I think there's some guys out
there that's married to three or fours
and they don't even know to this day so
I just think it's impossible to figure
out so you want to just vet the best way
you can and hope for the best
what do you think I agree yeah yeah I I
agree with that I gotta I gotta stir
this year so yeah I agree with that so
like you never to me
for most women they're not going to tell
because they've been talking to a woman
never Tails right so they're not going
to tell but you can observe their
patterns and if to me if their patterns
don't match what you want don't even
waste your time but you could be thrown
off with the pattern too so that's why I
just think you're just still not gonna
never know I mean they got hoes they got
tight cats so it's still not going
you can't even tell that way
I I think girls telling themselves
eventually I I think at some point like
you don't think if you're married to a
girl for like five years you're not
gonna get some inkling if she was in the
streets for 10. it's definitely
behaviors you could see yeah always what
behaviors do you guys look for she's too
friendly with men that's the number one
she can't cook the ultimate Telltale
sign she can't cook she was out there
that's just that's what I believe
it's like she's even taking on dates
like she hasn't had to pay for dinner in
10 years
uh
I would say if she's
if she's putting on my [ __ ] and she
pulled off my clothes
you know as soon as you get in there she
throwing my [ __ ] off I'll be like damn
like how many times you've done this
[ __ ] so um I would say that and then I
think the acts that they're doing too
they look like they're doing it too damn
good awesome porn [ __ ] it's like man
you showing up
what kind of footage you got out here
oh god
um yeah
I don't know I think
I feel bad for guys nowadays to be fair
like I think that's like
I don't know I don't like I have
brothers I don't even know how I would
tell them to like bet a girl because I
feel like
I don't know some like I think we could
all think of a girl that like you just
would never know you know
I'm gonna tell you something that I just
picked up uh not too long ago is
I want to know the relationship that she
has with her father absolutely I think
that's one of the most important thing
and I didn't even realized
how important it was until until now
because I know somebody that's like that
it's a complete difference it's a the
respect
um like the Loyalty like knowing how to
uh you know cater to a management and
Cadence not a bad thing right but just
knowing how to
like support your man is different when
the father's been active in their life
so I think that's one of the things that
I would tell my sons to do and I would
advise that any man that's watching this
right now see what type of relationship
they have with their father
what do you guys think of the statement
men want to be praised for basic
treatment
those are the same women that say they
don't do wife duties at girlfriend
status
yeah or they I don't want to be your mom
those are the same people saying this I
think they're irrelevant what are basic
what are basic things
I don't know I just got this from what
are basic things I know you know can you
repeat the question
men want to be
what do you think of the state
want to be praised for basic treatment
what are basic things like if they're
taking out the trash and like
yeah Americans don't appreciate things
Brazil and Brazil they appreciate over
there yeah
who have you been with
Americans
well I mean how many times have we heard
it yeah like I accepted the bare minimum
what's the bare minimum
and how many times do we hear men should
raise their standards or Not Sorry women
should raise their standards
like it's kind of ingrained in our
society that like women are
I don't know like we're kind of better
like near the supremacist yeah yeah
what do you think of that statement I
think it is it is true and women should
I don't care if he's if you got a man
that's coming home to you every every
night every day loves you what's wrong
with a little praise you want to be
praised if you make dinner if you put on
a dress or you know I mean the house
looks nice so give that man the
equivalent I think it's a good thing a
woman should embrace that
um I'm gonna say uh
I don't think she has to phrase you with
words but more so actions I think a lot
of guys can
can see their appreciation based off how
the woman is is acting so you may be
sitting at the desk and she may you know
get on her her knees and legs and just
start putting lotion on you and your
feet and just massage you uh she may
just uh go decide to cook or give you a
massage just think there you can just
see their appreciation without having
been to be acknowledged via words
what do you guys
I've heard
um you know don't praise a fish for
swimming because
um that's what men are supposed to do
he's supposed to open the door he's
supposed to provide
um but yeah I agree I think it's silly
because like no one is obligated to you
know do these things for you and if
you're in a relationship with someone
you should be showing appreciation and
reciprocating so I think it's a silly
thing that it's very too common yeah I
think if a woman doesn't like praise her
man maybe he won't feel appreciated and
he won't continue to go to do those
small things so I even a small smile are
like kissing your man or hugging them
just those small things
um will continue to
um to get that man to do those things
for you right I agree
do you do that
yeah I do I'm not in a relationship
right now but even if I if I go on a
date and somebody does small things for
me of course yeah I just have to ask
okay
do you not think no I just had an ass I
had to test her
okay I did have a question for the uh
I guess it might be for the ladies uh
somebody said that a man should never
leave a home without getting a nut
you guys think that's true please
I don't think that's possible every day
what if you have busy mornings here we
go
but I mean you can every day is fine but
I think there's like so I'm gonna say it
again A man should never leave a house
without getting a nut
I mean
I disagree
it can't be what if you're coming in and
out all day yeah
that's fine don't you want to have sex
yeah
every time he leaves the house I mean I
mean maybe we'll talk about it in the
morning and say you guys living together
so you make sure you take care of your
man before he leaves the house well yeah
because then he's going to get it
somewhere else
but you said it's impossible no I meant
like every single time he leaves the
house what if he leaves the house no I'm
talking about in the morning in the
morning I said before he leaves the
house yeah so is he just leaving the
house
like I'm not talking about coming back
leave and come back leaving I'm just
standing in the morning whatever time
what's 4 AM 6 a.m 7 A.M before he leaves
the house
a man a woman should make sure that man
get his nut
now are y'all practicing that
seriously in a relationship this is
advice
I've heard I've heard um keep his belly
full and um balls empty sure and I think
that every I understand what you guys
are saying like you know the everyday
thing that every morning yeah
um especially with kids especially with
kids and stuff like I can understand why
the pushback but
um if like probably like four four or
four days out of the week yeah my house
is crazy because I thought the woman's
sex drive increases uh over time no I
thought a single mothers be ready
um
I I agree with you I I think you should
like I was just saying every morning
yeah and then you just sit there and
take it like it's not like oh my God
what's it like you're doing the work you
can also do some head too I mean you
don't have to do it in the form up on
your back ladies I'm telling you
this is facts right you you'll be amazed
two things if your man is competitive
he's building something somebody's gonna
try to give it to him it just is what it
is right so the other thing is when you
give it to him he only has Focus for you
at that point because he empty he get a
chance to focus on his real stuff and
then the third thing is offer it to him
give him the option to say no baby I'm
good this morning and you'll be amazed
that might work wonders so it might turn
into four days a week right but give
them the option and that's just as good
you guys you guys have any other
questions
anyone on the panel it's gonna open for
you guys if you have questions
I'm curious to know about your marriage
what is kept that alive do you have any
Secret Sauce that you would give to I
normally charged with this okay
you got a girl you have to grow like
getting married at 19 uh group it grew
me up really fast
um and having a kid so you have to grow
really fast and um you have to assert
yourself in this world because at 19 you
don't know anything you don't actually I
should have got a minute 19. but what it
what but what life life does is it
forces you to either grow up or you're
going to get you know you're going to
check out
um so the first things you got to mature
the second thing is is my wife she grew
and she believed in our marriage when I
was focused on work she was focused on
our family and in a marriage
somebody has to be focused on the family
when somebody is working otherwise you
guys are not going to make it yeah and
the third thing is I'm a man of Faith so
I I I I I make sure that I pray for my
wife I pray for what we have and and
then we keep that bond together and then
every day you try it and you do it over
again so there's no secret sauce it's
just work and somebody's got to be
putting in effort yeah
thank you yeah
let's see my P.O box for the check
I'm curious being like a religious guy
do you
what do you think about like Born Again
virgins
there's no such thing do you think that
girls should have a guy wait even though
she like lost her virginity or whatever
like slept around before see this is
such a yeah she's gonna put you on
punishment okay so I find it interesting
so here's my thing is if do you want to
be married so that's the first thing if
you're with a person who you want to be
married to take that seriously and let
let that be known up front uh and if
this guy's if he's older established
then he's going to know that so don't
put it all because if you're over 30
you're trying to get it in let's just be
honest right and if not you've got
you've got some products that you know
take care of yourself so we take you
know be good uh but I don't believe in
the concept of born-again virgins I
believe that a person can be born again
but that doesn't erase what has happened
to you and so you have to own that and
now the real thing is how do you learn
from that is if you learn from that and
you've grown from that and you've really
transformed then that's something we can
talk about but I think the whole born
again it turns off me being able to ask
you questions about your past well I
just think that sometimes the church
kind of like leaves girls single because
like they kind of encourage them to give
a bad deal to guys like why would a guy
wait if you gave it to the last 10 for
free and so like if you're doing the
born like even if they don't say born
again virgin like a lot of times they'll
encourage them to wait but it's like
you're 32 like what is that a man
yeah yeah and it's like
what guy's gonna sign up for that if he
doesn't get a virgin at the end what do
you do you agree with that disagree
um I think a woman should if she wants
to be married she she should be sure
that this is going somewhere before she
does anything I her I'm traditional so
wait wait till you're married but I
realize the word that we live in so my
thing is don't be celibate to get a
husband be celibate because you're born
again yeah right let that be the premise
and then when you have a new
relationship he benefits from your
decision yeah but you don't think
that'll leave her sink because I'm just
thinking like I see so many girls in the
church that are like 30 and they're
celibate and I'm like what dude
only on Sundays
oh so they're just they're just saying
that and this is not for everyone but
I'm I've been around this world for a
long time yeah if they're telling you
are they lying they're Catherine some
are question asking for how long
how long will they say yeah that's what
I'm saying
get the response and then you'll see
like people lie people like that they
feel like they got to protect themselves
yeah and that's just human nature okay
do you guys have any questions
you should tell oh come on somebody I
just want to say I
I you do you guys think that we we
always talk about the Modern Woman and
stuff but do you guys also think that
men have like a say in how modern Dayton
is for the men
have a say like no like um a
responsibility of um to blame
for for how dating is or is it just like
but it's like this compared to y'all you
know so to be honest y'all blame for a
lot they invented birth control so it's
kind of there we allowed y'all to do
everything yeah
but y'all asked for it so
yeah I would agree it's it's real small
yeah I mean I think it starts with the
one but then if um if we're gonna say
the patriarchy you know like we were
oppressed and
um men allowed us to vote and Men
allowed us to to have birth control and
um you know the families movement and
stuff so then technically
isn't it men's responsibility to kind of
like stop all of that freedom comes with
consequences and yeah I wanted freedom
I I don't I would argue
the triarchy either
because like men women had more power
than most men in history
it's just like a small percentage of men
had all the power
you know the US was started right they
like kidnapped a bunch of dudes in
England and like threw them on the east
coast and said start Jamestown they
tried to do it with women and they
literally said they literally said that
we can't do that to the girls and then
like they let the girls go and then they
kidnapped another group of men for round
two after most of the first ones died
what do women have been able to build it
anyway though oh God now
that's what I mean like we've ever had
to fight in Wars like I just don't when
we say that there was a patriarchy I
just don't think that's true because who
had to fight in Wars who had to
sacrifice their bodies to build Society
not us
men were still in Georgia
yeah you could you could argue that like
a small percentage of men but like so if
you're gonna say that men had all the
power what percent of men had all the
power well it doesn't matter what
percent they were men they weren't women
but I'm saying like like it's a small
percentage of men so I'm saying like
most women have more power than most men
because they were viewed higher in
society they got more privileges like
for example the privilege not to go to
war
uh
I don't know I don't believe it well I
mean I believe that part yeah but no
I mean no
you know you know it was illegal to
divorce your husband at one point that's
the man's power
it was illegal to divorce your husband
at one point but I think there is like
reasons behind it because a lot of times
like the laws that look bad on paper
like there was ways around it when they
like explain it more
like because they say like women
couldn't have a bank account but I
remember like it's not necessarily true
um and like there was some way that a
lot of women like that didn't do that
got around it
I didn't know about that if you go in
more in a bank account then like I I'm
gonna butcher this and that's like I
don't but I just remember like
like Rolo tomasi was explaining it like
it wasn't that women couldn't get a bank
account but it was like
it was something with debt like women
tended to get more debt and so like they
couldn't qualify yeah yeah it was
something like that and it wasn't
necessarily that they like couldn't get
a big I don't want to like say it's just
a lot of times when they act like women
were oppressed like the more I learn
about it it's like they weren't actually
oppressed like because if men built
these institutions and then they allowed
women to be a part of them you know so
it's kind of like how are you oppressed
oh you're not a person anymore and
they're also the most unhappy people on
the planet right now
so I feel like we should also here I
kind of want to give back driving
huh yeah I want to give I kind of hate
driving
I want to like give it back
oh like in the Middle East yeah I kind
of like what they got there
[Laughter]
I don't know how long you'll think like
this
passenger yeah I don't know about that
one that's a that's a big Power To Give
Up yeah
I'm just I'm just kidding yeah
[Laughter]
I do have one question for everybody for
the ladies yeah yeah do the ladies do
you guys value marriage and would you
consider yourself more of a
traditionalist a traditional wife or a
more of a modern one
I absolutely value Mary I would love to
be married someday and
maybe I don't can you define what the
modern marriage may be compared to the
more traditional is that meaning like
the male does in traditional the male
contributes just the stuff can you yep
she takes care of Home takes care of a
man takes care of her family primarily
that's her focus and she's not as is
focused on her career family comes first
yeah I think for me right now like
there's a point in my career that I
wanna work but at some point I would
love to be a stay-at-home mom and would
love to
um you know raise my children with good
values and have them in like where it's
kind of like you want the Best of Both
Worlds huh I guess yeah yeah
um I agree with that I I believe in
traditional marriage but not
so like where you're just at home and
taking care of the kids like where are
you at you know
I think for me
I think for me I'm I value family and
with you know family comes marriage I
can't have kids also wedlock so it's
more like
um it answers your traditional question
because I'll put my family over my
career
um so if my husband needs me to go out
to work then I'm willing to
um if he needs me to stay home whatever
works best for the family
amazing
um you know I get this question a lot
um I would say I think traditional women
are like 22 year old virgins so I don't
think you can claim to be traditional
like I genuinely feel like like unless
you have like a cookbook and you're you
know like an actual traditional woman
you can't claim to be traditional so I
would say I'm modern but I have
Traditional Values
um like I really value
um my family and my parents and like
that but yeah no definitely you have to
be modern because
not a 22 year old version but I think
it's like the values do you have more
modern values or like traditional value
so would you like
like 50 50
. well I think family should be like
Families First no matter what like I I
think like you're
like I don't know like what what is a
career if you have no family so I I
think like family is always first but
the problem is I think a lot of times
like as women we want to claim to be
traditional but you can't be traditional
if you're not you don't got a cookbook
you don't like you know I think the main
difference between modern women and
traditional women is their um their
career for versus their family like they
don't want to give up
um that income or give up that status so
um that's why I consider myself a
traditional even though technically I'm
not a 22 year old virgin but I have more
Traditional Values because my career
does not come nowhere close to my family
and my husband
oh yeah
does that answer your question it does
yeah
does anyone else have any other
questions
no
I like to give podcast people if they
have um questions they want to ask that
something I feel like I feel like you've
um nothing okay well um I have a
question Austin who hurt you I'm joking
he's trying to run away
I've never been hurt
okay well um thank you guys for coming
out this is fun
um thank you thank you to end um the
podcast why don't you go around everyone
give final thoughts and you know plug
your YouTubes and whatnot so you start
and go this way again I'm awesome
Halloween my YouTube is awesome
Halloween and if you can relate to my
videos you need to get your passport
because it's that bad you need to leave
women in the United States alone
seriously you don't know how bad it is
until you leave
my name is Sergio speaks it was really
good being with all everybody today so
glad to be here
um I believe in marriage I believe in
relationships and I think that people
who want it I have to do the work it
takes to make those relationships viable
and great and if you want to be great at
that subscribe to my channel sir hell
speaks I'll be glad to see you guys over
there I'm Jessica Barrera it's been a
great time talking with all of you I've
learned a lot about marriage
relationships I'm currently single so if
you wanna mingle go on a date
[Laughter]
shoot your shot guys
my name is Diana
um it was nice meeting all you guys and
it was nice discussing all these topics
and um yeah I don't have a YouTube
channel I'm Chantelle Chantel Simone um
my channel is you know for women who
want to learn how to be traditional and
we were raised modern we were raised
independent so we try to brainstorm ways
to um be better wives
all right I'm La Peep Jr and
part of the Latif Network that's
l-a-p-e-e-f Network
excuse me and I just want to say thank
you uh Miss pearly for the opportunity
to bless the platform is good meeting
some of you guys in person and good
being for the first time uh give us a
follow over there at the LA people
Network let's just have the conversation
as I always say
okay guys
um thank you all for coming
um don't forget to like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and don't forget I have four membership
tiers okay if you guys want to grow on
YouTube I really recommend my fourth
tier that's a one-on-one call with me
once a month third tier um you connect
with me on social media second tier um
you get to be a part of our Discord
which I'm getting real good at Discord
so you should definitely be a part of
that I just learned it my sister's been
teaching me
um also you get our behind the scenes
Vlogs we just moved into a really cool
Penthouse
um so we did a whole Vlog on like the
behind the scenes what it looks like if
you want to see sign up for that one and
first year you get to be a part of the
live chat don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and we will talk to you next
time
I